foreign
walking has become almost impossible for
72 year old Kadir tontoosh
his house was destroyed by the
earthquake and he's now living in a
container
kadir's wife zeliha says her husband
desperately needs a wheelchair
[Music]
we don't know what to do either he needs
to be taken to a special Care Center or
he needs an electrical wheelchair so he
can go outside he's always indoors with
these crutches
we found them in a container in islahia
a town that like so many others was
devastated by the earthquakes last month
they're not the only ones struggling to
cope with the situation
is also living here and was waiting for
surgery before the earthquake happened
and so is hathije who's struggling with
paralysis there's over 8 million people
with disabilities in turkey and many are
living in the areas affected by the
earthquake surviving in a disaster zone
is a major challenge because it's not
only difficult for them to reach the Aid
distribution points but also their
shortages of wheelchair crutches and
other personal care items
not far away in another town selver is
22 years old and has special needs
the rehabilitation center she attended
was also damaged during the earthquakes
and that's why she's here at this
kindergarten that was set up an attempt
for children who have lost their homes
I told my mother an earthquake is
happening I cried and was afraid it was
raining
children here do Sports and music
activities teachers are hoping to help
them forget about the struggles they're
facing every day
we have five disabled students here our
Specialists spend time with them
individually as we know what they like
doing in the past we do the same
activities with them now so they can
remember the past
hardship is everywhere in Southeastern
turkia these days and while many are
struggling to cover their most basic
needs others like adirondouch are
desperate for more help that will allow
them to cope with a new life
turkey